this is the view from the keek family
home
next door the hadidis once lived a
family now without a mother
and four of her sons the keeks somehow
survived three generations and holding
together just
the sound is the israeli drones they've
been low overhead through the day
hitting targets across the strip
[Music]
the weight of one family's struggle is
on him
then there is the other generation his
daughters
how do you explain to them why their
neighbors their friends are dead
there is no innocence in gaza
there is water here but it no longer
comes out of the taps
the bombing has damaged the mains pipes
it's taken out the electricity supply
too
it's down to a maximum of two hours a
day now and there is little fuel for the
generators
[Music]
this is islam muhammad's sister so bad
so
scary
so bad
the un run schools are a focal point
classrooms are now bedrooms for the many
hundreds of families whose houses are
destroyed
and the thousands more who are too
frightened to be home
the families here tell us there has been
an air strike every five minutes
for a population locked in and already
seventy percent dependent on aid and
food
this is devastating but with footage
like this
as evidence of what they say are as
precise strikes as possible
the israeli military claim they have
killed 130 palestinian militants
this they say is the targeting of a
small hamas submarine
and this was for israel a prize they
claimed they killed a top commander
who sam was for 15 years a leader
within the palestinian islamic jihad
yet despite all this there is no sign a
weak on
that either side is prepared to stop not
even for aid to get in
israel calls this proportionate and
civilian deaths regrettable
hamas says it is the defender of the
palestinian people
the cycle goes on marc stone sky news